tu avais été lancée et cette enquête qui
a été fait dans les ardennes comme dans
les autres départements a permis de
suspecter les différents éléments et en
particulier le talk la marque orange qui
se retrouver dans les soins donnés à
tous ces enfants des échantillons de ce
talk repris dans les familles des
enfants malades ont été adressées au
service central des carnassiers les
analyses ont été faites à l'hôpital
fernand widal et ont permis de mettre en
évidence un produit
dangereux que posséder ce talk monsieur
cloche vous aviez une petite fille de 6
mois
il est morte le 12 juin dernier nous
jouons alors pouvez vous nous raconter
les circonstances de ce décès et bien
c'est à dire j'ai vu nerveuse a été
happée nerveuse fait venir le médecin
tout ça francis peter de montcy puis les
reds et la musique amazighe rarement
comme en face on s'arrange
puis c'est à dire avant la douche loire
accueille talk s'était pas ce talent que
là j'avais avancé telle taxe si c'était
des études et tu es venue du john
rigolote du canon puis ma femme est
redescendu avec le dj plus tard mais on
a surgi du match pour mon estomac et la
ministre bachelot l'ami de la nasa
gratis gratis et faisait des pleins et
puis c'était la meuse et dorment plus la
nuit puis le lendemain matin quand j'ai
trouvé lundi moi quand je suis revenue
une midi jeudi n'a pas fait venir le
médecin
baldino je sais pas ce que je réalise
plus ridicule étaient là elles comme à
quoi si finir la bulle allait appeler
les pompiers puis long de la manche et
thiap et les mendiants près alors qu'est
ce qu'on vous a dit ben non pas des
définitions ils ont dit elle est morte
suite soit disant du match à caen dans
les convictions et sa durée combien de
temps totale depuis depuis le jour où
vous avez utilisé ça commencé le
handball c'est raté et ça a duré combien
de temps avant le 12 juin
deux journaux de trois jours - valérie
ma journée mais les trois jours